PROFESSOR: All right,
so how do we solve this?
This is a very
interesting thing,
and I think it points to all
kinds of important things
that people find
useful in physics.
So here it is, the way,
maybe, we can think about it.
Think variational method.
What is the variational method?
You write a wave
function and you
try to see what
is the expectation
value of the Hamiltonian
and that wave function.
You calculate it, and now you
know that the ground state
energy is below that number.
Because for the
real ground state
expectation value
of the Hamiltonian
is the ground state energy.
For an arbitrary state
it's more than that.
So the variational
method says, OK,
if you want to figure
out what is a good wave
function, compute the
expectation value of your wave
function in the Hamiltonian,
and then you will see,
you will get some energy.
If you tinker with
your wave function
you can get to the right energy.
So this is what
we're going to do
we're going to try to
take this psi of r, r
and put the total
Hamiltonian here.
And now that psi of r, r is
going to be this one from now
on.
This is psi of r, r.
We'll put it here, and then
I'll put another psi of r, r.
And I have to compute that.
But think of it-- it's actually
pretty nice, the situation.
Computing this, you
could say how can I
compute that if I don't know
the etas, the single eta that
is there?
I know the Hamiltonian
but I don't know the eta,
so I can't compute this.
But think of this really, this
is an integral, because there's
an [INAUDIBLE] over
all the capital R's,
an integral over the little
r's, and you can say,
oh, I know the little r's here.
I know them very well.
I found them.
I found this phi r.
I've determined it.
Some way you did.
So if I know that, I know
the little r dependence,
and I can do all the
little r integrals.
If I can do all the
little r integrals,
means that this wave
function is a product,
this wave function
is a product, this
I can reduce to the following.
Eta of r, because this one I
don't know, and then eta of r,
and I claim that
all the part that
had to do with the phi
of r, we can take care,
and then there's going to be
some Hamiltonian here left.
And this we're going to
call h effective of the r
degrees of freedom.
So a lot of physics
in that step.
Seems like we did
nothing, but look,
I'm supposed to minimize this
by adjusting my trial wave
functions.
OK, but I don't have
room to adjust the phi,
because I determined
that it's a good one.
So I put it in and
I calculate this.
Now I have to minimize this.
But if I have to minimize
this for just v nuclear wave
function, I have found
the effective Hamiltonian
for the nuclei, in which
the electron has essentially
disappeared from
this interaction.
It just doesn't
play a role anymore.
This is the idea of
effective Hamiltonians
for slow degrees of
freedom when you integrate
fast degrees of freedom.
The fast degrees of
freedom are your electrons.
We're getting rid of them,
we're integrating them.
We're going to try to do that.
So this will be an
effective Hamiltonian
for the nuclear
degrees of freedom.
So let me do one term in here.
One term, you can play
trying to do other terms,
and the notes will
deal with that.
So let's consider the term He.
This Hamiltonian is
some terms plus He.
It's over there.
So let's calculate what He does.
So I now have to
put effect of He.
So I have to put here eta of r--
so let me put the whole thing.
It's integral over all the R's--
R1, R2, R3-- integral
over all the little r's.
That's an overlap.
Eta star of all the R's--
that's the [INAUDIBLE],,
phi star R of little r, He, then
etas of capital R, phi R of r.
Everybody happy?
That's my term.
That's the contribution of
He to the left hand side.
Good?
Now He is an operator and
looks at this thing and says,
well, I don't think derivatives
with respect to capital R,
so I'm there.
I take the derivatives
with respect to little r,
I have a multiplicative factor,
another multiplicative factor.
So I basically act
just directly on this.
But He already acting
on that gives you
the electronic energy.
So this would be the electronic
energy in the ground state.
That depends on R times
phi R. And lots of vectors.
OK.
So this integral now becomes
integral dR eta star of R.
Then I'll put the other
integral, integral dr, phi
of r, star of r.
And then I have just this
number times eta of R.
All right, so what
is this integral?
Happily, this is just a number.
It goes out of this, it's
an orthonormal state.
So this whole thing is dR eta
star of R, Ee of R, eta of R,
which you could say is eta of
R, the number Ee of R times
eta of R, and therefore
you've confirmed
that the contribution to the
effective Hamiltonian of all
this electron cloud is just this
number, the electronic energy
like that.
So in the effective
Hamiltonian, h effective,
there will be some
terms and there will
be Ee of R. That's one term.
OK, so what is the whole answer
for the effective Hamiltonian?
No way to guess it, I
think, unless you're--
well, you have
incredible intuition.
It's going to be a
little complicated.
If you think about it, why?
Suppose this term is going to
create no trouble whatsoever.
It's just going to copy itself.
This thing doesn't act on
the electronic wave function,
so the electronic wave
function's going to cancel,
is just going to
contribute by itself.
So this term we've done.
This term is easy.
It just gives itself.
But this term is tough, because
this term takes derivatives
with respect to capital
R, and your wave function
depends on capital R. So
it's going to be interesting.
So what is the answer?
I want to give you
the answer rather than
do that calculation.
And it's almost like
sometimes physics
seems to have just a
limited bag of tricks,
and things come out in some
way or another in a simple way.
So what is the
effective Hamiltonian?
You could say, OK, it's going
to be the sum of kinetic terms,
2m alpha over alpha, and
you have p alpha squared.
Well, it's not going to
be just p alpha squared.
There's going to
be a little more.
And then there's going to be
a potential, a great potential
of R, and that
great potential of R
is going to include the
nuclear nuclear R potential.
We said that this nuclear
nuclear term would just
copy along.
The He we calculated, and
that gives us the Ee of R.
And you say, well,
maybe that's it,
but no, it's not
that, that's it.
So let's see what it gives you.
OK, so here it comes.
You remember
electromagnetism, you
could change this thing here?
Well, it gets changed, and it
will become p minus a alpha.
Like if there would
be a connection.
Like if there would be
an electromagnetic field.
There's no electromagnetic
field here, nothing whatsoever.
But there is one
thing, and what is it?
As we'll write here, it turns
out to be a Berry connection.
Because you have
the adiabatic thing
and you have your
states that depend on R,
the Berry connection shows up.
So it shows up like this here.
And here it shows up in
a couple of funny terms.
A term of the form
alpha h squared over
2m alpha, integral
vr, gradient sub r
alpha of phi r squared,
minus sum over alpha
a alpha squared over 2m alpha.
So that's the whole thing,
but I haven't defined the a.
What is the a?
Well, it's sort of
a Berry connection.
So you know what a
Berry connection is.
It's a v with a R in
configuration space of a wave
function with the star
wave function, integrated.
That was kind of a
Berry connection.
So it turns out to
be very similar here.
The a alpha vector
of R is ih bar,
the integral over the little
space-- the electron space.
That's where you
integrate things--
of the electric wave
function star times
the gradient with respect to
R alpha of the electron wave
function of R.
That is the Berry connection.
If you remember, it's an overlap
of wave function, wave function
and the gradient with respect
to the configuration space.
So that's a good
Hamiltonian for a molecule
in the adiabatic approximation.
If this looks
complicated, it's already
much simpler than what the
real problem is, because
of the adiabatic approximation.
If you have these
wave functions,
these electronic wave functions
you can calculate these a's.
And this plays the role of
the effective Hamiltonian
for the nuclei in
this approximation.
So the variational principle
essentially told us
what is the right
way to describe
the interactions of the nuclei,
given that the electrons have
already been fixed into a
class of wave functions.
Now in general, this is
the complete solution,
but in general it's hard to
do it, still complicated.
So many times, people simplify.
Well, it might
happen, for example,
if you have a simple enough
molecule that your wave
functions phi r are real.
Now you remember that the
Berry phase vanishes when
the wave functions are real.
These things have
to be imaginary.
With another i they
have to be real.
Connections are always real
operators in the sense of r.
So if the electronic wave
functions are real, forget it,
there's no Berry connection.
So many times the Berry
connections are not there.
Even if there are no
Berry connections,
this term might be there.
This is the gradient of this
wave function with respect
to the R. And this
term can be important,
even if there is no
Berry connection.
So in some cases, the lowest
order approximation of this--
I think that's what
this classically called
the [INAUDIBLE] Oppenheimer--
ignores the Berry phase and
ignores this extra term.
So in that approximation, the
lowest order approximation,
the effective
Hamiltonian, is just
the sum over alpha
minus h squared
over 2m alpha, Laplacian R
alpha plus the nuclear nuclear
potential, plus the electronic
contribution to the potential.
So you keep-- basically,
forget about Berry.
That's higher approximation,
higher order approximation,
higher order approximation.
Keep just the p, keep
the nuclear nuclear,
keep the electronic.
And people have done
a lot with this.
So that's how our
treatment of molecules.
A pretty interesting thing.
And perhaps the most important
lesson of all of this
is your way in which you can
see how light degrees of freedom
impose dynamics in slow
degrees of freedom.
And that's something you do
in physics, in quantum field
theory, all the time.
You have the slow-moving
degrees of freedom
and the fast-moving
degrees of freedom.
And you integrate the
fast-moving degrees of freedom,
and you find an effective
Hamiltonian for the big things.
You may have quarks and all
kinds of complicated things.
But at the end of the day,
they form protons and neutrons,
and you can integrate the
interactions of the quarks
to sort of find the dynamics of
the particle that you observe.
So that step in that top
blackboard is pretty important.